[Music]
this car looks possessed do you feel
sweaty
yeah mild sweaty can I try your hand
yeah definitely sweating if you've ever
read a book in a car chances are you
know what motion sickness feels like but
the causes of motion sickness remain
largely a mystery with the growth in
both ride-sharing and autonomous vehicle
technology we could have a lot more free
time in cars so can technology provide a
remedy for motion sickness
we're in suburban Boston today to learn
about a company called clear motion
which is working on a technology to try
to combat motion sickness the MIT born
clear motion was founded in 2009 their
mission to improve the quality of time
in motion the company has created a
digital suspension one that can adjust
the ride of the car throughout tronic
adjusters controlled by computers with
this clear motion hopes comes a
potential reduction in motion sickness
about 1 in 3 people are highly prone to
motion sickness that comes from movement
like traveling in cars boats and
airplanes according to the National
Institutes of Health some scientists
think motion sickness happens because
the brain is getting mixed messages the
inner ear in other parts of the body
sense that you're in motion but your
eyes are telling your brain that you're
still this is why reading in a bumpy car
can be a good trigger and traveling
facing backwards can be unnerving a
feature that is increasingly popular in
autonomous vehicle prototypes
researchers say that drivers don't
experience motion sickness as much as
passengers and as autonomous vehicles
begin to roll out there could be fewer
drivers and more passengers on the road
so next up we're going to show you the
dyno lab so here's where we could
actually do accelerated testing to
really prove out the system can last the
life of the car so we're going to
actually take this unit install it on
this dyno
and what we're gonna run is an actual
input profile so this is the active
valve so how it works is you have one of
these at each wheel of the car and it
actually has software and sensors built
into this and what it's doing is it's
sensing small perturbations from the
road that are moving the wheels and it's
sensing any sort of motion from the
vehicle itself and what it does is it
tries to cancel out that input you've
seen in suspension this is our next
generation products so here we're
actively isolating we're using a lot of
the similar software and controls but
we're actively isolating a seat
this platform is representing what would
be essentially a very rocky ride on the
roads and the seat there is not moving a
key thing for clear motion to figure out
was how effective its technology might
be at mitigating motion sickness to do
that they enlisted a team of Brandeis
University researchers who are
monitoring test subjects in vehicles
with both clear motion technology and
normal suspension I wanted to put the
clear motion technology to the test
myself so I joined Janet Kaplan a
researcher on the Brandeis team for an
unofficial test ride I get in two cars
one with Clear Motion technology and the
other with a normal suspension this was
a blind test
Kaplan did not tell me which car I'd be
traveling in prior to the ride how do
you feel comfortable or not comfortable
zero read the passage it's a three
minute read I'm reading something about
dream house how clearly were you able to
understand the text on
zero to ten scale three how would you
rate your nausea zero so this vehicle
seemed like this is the active safety I
told you as much yes it is so we're in
car number two we're gonna do it all
again
so press GO are we going on the same
road is before or is this a is this a
rougher road it's the same exactly now
you have to read the text
how nauseous did you feel well I'm
definitely aware that I have a stomach
okay what about understanding the text
tough go probably about a four I just
kind of feel like I'm moving around a
lot definitely wouldn't want to read a
lot we are done we can go back to the
base
Brandeis researchers tested dozens of
subjects for this project and found the
system helped delay and mitigate
symptoms but it's still early days over
who might implement the best
countermeasure for motion sickness clear
motion faces competition from tech and
auto giants after taking two cars on two
different test rides I can tell you that
I could tell the difference between
these vehicles the ride in the second
vehicle was a lot rougher a lot less of
an enjoyable experience it was difficult
to pay attention to the reading material
and I can imagine a situation if this
was an autonomous car and I had all the
time in the world to be reading I
wouldn't want to be doing it and which
underscores really why this company and
others are trying to develop technology
to combat motion sickness so one of the
challenges in this sector is that some
only some automakers and some tech
companies were very enthusiastic about
the deployment of fully autonomous
vehicles since then we've seen kind of
pull back in some of these timelines how
does that affect you as you try to
supply them for the parts they need in
the future
yeah so that's that's one of the keys
we've got a product that meets a need
today which is better ride
and safety and then you have this sort
of longer-term story so for us the
potential push out of autonomy is not a
huge factor because all of our contracts
today are really around you know
supplying to vehicles that are being
produced I'd say another thing that's
also interesting is this concept of the
head start I mean people are finally
finally recognizing that EVs are going
to be very important and Tesla's
effectively operating this bubble for a
decade they've got a serious head start
from the other automakers
and likewise we see sort of this sort of
Head Start mentality where starting out
in the premium segment we've built a
patent portfolio of 280 patents so far
then we see this sort of head start
let's get out there
prove out the technology as soon as this
market comes and we're gonna be running
clear motion has raised about two
hundred and eighty million dollars to
date with participation from Microsoft
and Bridgestone these kinds of
investments show that investors are
thinking about what needs to occur after
driverless cars or deployed years from
now and what humans are going to need as
passengers
you
[Music]